okay so that's general relativity
and what's its friendly neighbor like
you said theories
quantum mechanics right so quantum
mechanics the the
the sort of the way that that originated
was one question was is the world
continuous or is it discrete
you know in ancient greek times people
have been debating this people debated
it
you know throughout history is light
made of waves is it continuous is it
discrete is it made of particles
corpuscles
whatever um you know what had become
clear in the 1800s
is that atoms that you know materials
are made of discrete atoms
you know when you take some water the
water is not a continuous fluid even
though it seems like a continuous fluid
to us
at our scale but if you say let's look
at it's more and smaller and smaller and
smaller scale eventually you get down to
these
you know these molecules and then atoms
it's made of discrete things
the question is sort of how important is
this discreteness just what's discrete
what's not discrete is energy discrete
is you know is what's discrete what's
not
and so does it have mass those kinds of
questions
yeah yeah right well the there's
question for example is mass discrete is
an interesting question
which is now something we can address
but but um
you know what what happened in um uh the
in in the coming up to the 1920s
there was this kind of mathematical
theory developed that could explain
certain kinds of discreteness
in in particularly in in features of
atoms and so on
and uh you know what developed was this
mathematical theory
that was the theory the theory of
quantum mechanics theory of wave
functions schrodinger's equation things
like this
that's a mathematical theory that allows
you to calculate lots of features of the
microscopic world lots of things about
how atoms work
etc etc etc now the calculations all
work just great
the um the question of what does it
really mean
is a complicated question now i mean to
to just explain a little bit
historically
the you know the early calculations of
things like atoms worked great
1920s 1930s and so on there was always a
problem there were
uh in quantum field theory which is a
theory of
uh in quantum mechanics you're dealing
with a certain number of at a certain
number of electrons
and you fix the number of electrons you
say i'm dealing with a two electron
thing um in quantum field theory you
allow for particles being created and
destroyed
so you can emit a photon that didn't
exist before you can absorb a photon
things like that
that's a more complicated mathematically
complicated theory and it had all kinds
of mathematical issues and all kinds of
infinities that cropped up
and it was finally figured out more or
less how to get rid of those
but there were only certain ways of
doing the calculations and those didn't
work for atomic nuclei among other
things
um and that led to a lot of development
up until the 1960s of alternative ideas
for how
how one could understand what was
happening in atomic nuclei et cetera et
cetera
end result in the end the kind of most
obvious mathematical structure of
quantum field theory
seems to work although it's
mathematically difficult to deal with
but you can calculate all kinds of
things you can calculate to you know
a dozen decimal places certain certain
things you can measure them it all works
it's all beautiful
now the underlying fabric is the model
of that
particular theory is fields like you
keep saying fields
those are quantum fields those are
different from classical fields
uh a field is something like you say
um there's like you say the temperature
field in this room it's like
there is a value of temperature at every
point around the room
that's um or you can say the wind field
would be the
the vector direction of the wind at
every point it's continuous
yes and it's a that's a classical field
the quantum field is a much more
mathematically elaborate
kind of thing um and i should explain
that that one of the pictures of quantum
mechanics that's really important
is you know in classical physics one
believes that sort of definite things
happen in the world you
pick up a ball you throw it the ball
goes in a definite trajectory that's
the has certain equations of motion it
goes in a parabola or whatever else
in quantum mechanics the picture is
definite things don't happen instead
sort of what happens is this whole
sort of structure of of all you know
many different paths being followed
and we can calculate certain aspects of
what happens
certain probabilities of different
outcomes and so on and you say
well what really happened what's really
going on what's the sort of
what's the underlying you know what's
the underlying story what how do we
how do we turn this this mathematical
theory that we can calculate things with
into something that we can really
understand and have a narrative about
and that's been really really hard for
quantum mechanics my
my friend dick feynman always used to
say nobody understands quantum mechanics
even though he'd made his you know whole
career out of calculating
things about quantum mechanics um and uh
you know so
so nevertheless it's uh what the
quantum field theory is very uh very
accurate at predicting
a lot of the physical phenomena so it
works
yeah and but the things about it you
know it has certain
when we apply it the standard model of
particle physics for example
we uh you know which we apply to
calculate all kinds of things that works
really well
you say well it has certain parameters
it has a whole bunch of parameters
actually
they say why is the you know why does
the muon particle exist
why is it 206 times the mass of the
electron
we don't know no idea
you